estas son las dos formas que te vas a
encontrar de cómo se define la derivada
en términos del límite generalmente
usamos esta definición si estamos
pensando en la derivada en un punto y
generalmente usamos esta forma cuando
estamos pensando en la derivada en
general para cualquier punto x pero en
realidad estas dos definiciones son
equivalentes las 2 están describiendo la
pendiente de la línea tangente y también
la tasa de cambio instantáneo y ahora
usando estas definiciones quiero
establecer las propiedades básicas de
las derivadas la primera propiedad que
vamos a ver puede llegar a parecer que
es algo como sentido común por lo menos
una vez que la veamos así se va a sentir
pero esta propiedad nos dice que si una
función f de x es igual a una constante
entonces
efe prima de x es igual a 0
porque esto podría ser sentido común
bueno para que veas que si es algo como
sentido común vamos a graficar lo este
es el eje de este es el eje x es el eje
x si gráfica mos fx igual a la constante
que se ve así donde este es el valor de
igual acá y esta es la gráfica de igual
a fx y aquí obsérvalo fijamente no
importa cómo vamos a x ya no cambia la
pendiente de la recta tangente bueno de
hecho la tangente es la misma recta no
importa cuánto cambie x sigue teniendo
el mismo valor no cambia nada la
pendiente es igual a 0 y no cambia nunca
no importa cuánto cambie x y bueno de
hecho podemos utilizar cualquiera de
estas dos definiciones para establecerlo
formalmente y es lo que vamos a hacer
es que ponemos por aquí el límite cuando
h tiende a cero de f de x + h pero sin
importar qué valor tengamos aquí efe
siempre es igual a la constante k así es
que aquí tenemos f x + h igual acá
- efe x pero otra vez no importa en qué
valor evaluemos a efe siempre nos da k y
eso lo estamos dividiendo entre h ahora
esto de aquí es simplemente cero así es
que aquí tenemos 0 / h por lo que este
límite es igual a 0
así es que f prima de x para cualquier
valor de x es igual a cero y eso es
justo lo que estábamos viendo por aquí
la pendiente de la recta tangente que es
esta misma recta para cualquier valor de
x la pendiente es 0 así es que si vas
muy feliz' campante por la calle y
alguien llega y te dice oye si tienes
una función f
que evaluada en x es igual a pi cuál es
la derivada de f
bueno pues tú en ese momento dices ok sí
es una constante entonces
efe prima de x la derivada de una
función que es constante la tasa de
cambio instantáneo de una constante la
pendiente de la recta tangente de una
función constante o la tasa de cambio
instantáneo de una constante eso siempre
es igual a cero